hello rejects Greg is here John is here
so we're gonna watch the trailer that
just dropped that not knows dropping
transformers the last night official
trailer number one my favorite franchise
and sucks if there's anything I know
about my experience with all the
Transformers movies is that I love the
trailers but I end up not liking the
movie so here we go
can't wait to love this trailer it's
gonna be epic
the coverage is being said I think it's
like a park it's really cool without
sacrifice that could be no victory to
species at war
[Music]
the Dark Knight Rises the cool cover
under national ones oiled-up
wonderful boy Optimus Prime has left us
again again you stop doing that up oh
he's like dead though 100 billion
trillion planets in the cosmos this
character from West world
I'm bigger than so he did happen yeah
[Music]
Oh No
well you see the man I love and I want
to fight that
it's not town two worlds colliding
the operation so will I keep it up okay
back only one survives
[Music]
whoa Oh what what is he doing
that's a cool trail there's a cool
[ __ ] trailer that is a really culture
they got different riders that's a
really cool trailer yeah it's a very
cool thing they got different riders
could be totally wrong
you know Orci and Kurtzman I think wrote
the first year okay I don't know who
wrote the fourth one this is the trailer
they made another one of the trailer
yeah where it's like an intense
narration and some really striking
images all set to a dreary cover of
something I got a mint Oh like after you
know finally getting into Game of
Thrones is about a month ago on the
fourth season now the first like 10
seconds or 20 seconds of this trailer
when it's all like medieval times
it's right up today that look cool
everything in this like I love this
trailer like everything in this trailer
looks [ __ ] awesome yeah at least was
a dragon transformers was awesome hey I
really like the animal transformers in
fact when that trailer for the second
one or whatever came out were like that
one that looks kind of like a like a
panther comes out of the ocean like
[ __ ] awesome like I like the the
designs of the animal ones yeah more
than just the humanoid ones the effects
do keep getting better and better like
they keep blending in with the world a
lot better this is somehow five movies
deep in still Hollywood like top
franchises like seem like they spare no
expense at all of these films whose the
house was Michael Bay is the director
yeah yeah I mean the this main chick
they're promoting Isabella mostly she's
15 16 years old 16 month on this movie
talk shows in the nut job to decide oh
man
animated classic job starring Will
Arnett one thing I appreciate about this
trailer ya know what I got is safe if
Michael Bay is not total perv satis and
doesn't try to make her [ __ ] hot as
sexy as hell let's see if being underage
can stop it yeah because thus far
nothing else has because she seemed like
a cool main character yeah I feel like
she was promoted more than Mark
Wahlberg's character yes my war was so
busy filming Peter Berg you never have
fun on the transfer is completely up to
date this trailer this trailer has the
cool potential female lead it's got the
dragon [ __ ] it's got the period warship
it's got cool side image reels marquee
over it seems really serious and like
it's got purpose now and what is more
personal good miss Primus prime is
killing bumblebee at the end of this
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah bumblebee simply
doesn't care a little bit about the
whole thing with him disappearing it's
like it's always a [ __ ] setup cuz he
you know hate you or whenever it
happened yeah like we know you're coming
back Optimus Prime is Michael they keep
saying he's done but he keeps doing more
I think they theoretical asked me but I
think like by now if they really got
their [ __ ] together they could if they
wanted to get ballsy and kill off
Optimus Prime I guess they could make
that happen somehow I don't think
they're not gonna do that now he's the
leader of the other bodies look the Otto
John there's no need to be so negative
we already know that there's a high
probability this film is gonna suck no I
think this traitor like if I had no idea
of the poetry I think this trailer is
wicked I've had bad respect that they're
not throwing some hot-ass female in
front of our face let me know of yet I'm
looking at this I'm DB so far I mean
who's Laura haddock okay she might be
the hot-ass female everyone's sweaty
basically what I'm trying to say is this
is an awesome trailer I had a great time
watching it it does nothing to convince
me that the movies will be any different
from the past movies though cuz all the
trailers are cool well one thing it does
look like a little different though is
it feels a little payin and keeping up
with modern times it feels a little bit
of pockle it it feels apocalyptic and I
do like like models are slightly has
some facial hair and he has like this
cool up-to-date gun and he looks like
he's kind of a traveler this is his
second chance at MEC yeah because it
looks like they're making him more of an
action star in this one yes I posted dad
on the run you saw an action hero but
now it's like nah he's wielding guns and
[ __ ] like he knows what he's doing this
time hey and if they do something like
that and they take licence give us a
cool actually man female protagonist
come on yeah it's a well it's a gigantic
you know action franchise so it's only
gonna get so interesting but I feel like
they could Fast and the Furious this
stuff and actually get my interest back
cuz like I as a viewer I've been stung
by these movies
too many times if they started to change
the genre now and they make mark walberg
just straight-up action badass or
something like that like I think that
would be go a beat really that would be
really cool and I could use that and
like I said I do like that they do seem
like they're throwing in a fantasy and I
and a more science fiction at least
visual aesthetic like there are some
places that look like they're out of the
future it's not just New York or
wherever you know here's a desert and
here's like a big Sky Dome and a planet
that's breaking apart instead of the
world just being attacked it seems like
this takes place a little bit more in
the future where the world is kind of
falling apart and I like that I like
that I think that's a great approach
yeah but here's what I know this is
which Transformers trailer is [ __ ]
amazing this makes me want to see this
movie but I know it's supposed to
because they always they're all good cuz
I just haven't feel it's gonna be
another two of our 30-minute film the
last one was 2 hours and 45 minutes yeah
now that's that's two so what if you're
doing and then they end up being like
weird comedy with bad drama and this
really drags out and then the action
scenes go on too long and nothing's
interesting unless you're gonna make
this some next-level allegorical matric
[ __ ] like transformers has got to know
what it is at someday but Todd
Hamilton's back Josh Duhamel yeah he's
he's back so stanley tucci and John
Tudor like somehow this happens yeah
it's as only if I just wish you know we
actually look forward to these movies to
go see those guys what's this that's
what bums me out about this trailer cuz
it's like it gets me excited for
everything that I know not to expect is
gonna actually turn out except
makes me sad cuz I'm like this Josh
Hamilton the last one so it's cool that
he's back hey when they bring Shia
LaBeouf back oh my oh my god they get
Shia LaBeouf my Oracle that I think I
wrap my life is some time we're actually
interested in the human you know what
bring megan fox back cause you hardly
read our feels so good at iris Gibson
Tyrese bring back his dad a bit on like
break back the whole I gosh transformers
bring in uh
bring John Bailey into the mix like
animated Optimus Prime in there like
let's just do a whole salad bowl dress
be cool and bring that gun face guy back
from part four I thought he was cool
this is supposedly his his last such
[ __ ]
you see I'm like three transformer is
like the only director who's gotten to
do five consecutive films of a franchise
that doesn't seem like it's deteriorated
at all no like this doesn't happen like
I mean congrats to them for getting five
films deep and still getting bigger
something yeah you know he knows what
he's doing
yeah you notice how they make money he's
personally working on a VR experience
it's nine minutes long a transformers
and I read a whole interview with him on
it it sounds really [ __ ] exciting and
that gods did that just happen to be
reading that and then I hadn't seen
notification that this pops up I just
feel like it's transformers is meant to
be in my life right now
hey I would love to see a like a VR
transformers experience it sounds me
right now Versalles awesome and another
thing - Optimus Prime hurting his own
that'll probably end by the finale and
he'll be a hero yeah but at least they
didn't show it to us but rate yeah
that's gonna be the civil war motors
look it's gonna be like ah they both got
a point though like that's how bumblebee
yeah movi can't be dead
I keep hearing they're trying to make a
solo bumblebee they can't be do it
that's the problem with movie news yeah
it's gonna end up like an episode of The
Walking Dead and Anthony Hopkins is a
nice addition that's a pretty serious
credible actor that's that's the thing I
mean Hawkins is a way higher par the
daddy other crew let's come on every one
of these movies they're able to make at
least one casting choice where I'm like
interesting I wonder how they entice to
this actor into doing this unless
they're wells money money is a major
enticement for an actor who doesn't get
leading naturally six and the Hagins a
little Garcias yeah but I don't I don't
know I don't feel like an t Hopkins
needs to do transformers like I don't
the [ __ ] does he need to do cuz he's
okay he's got Westworld and he's
probably happy for you same time like I
just feel like his narration was a
little bit like he he seems like the
west-world but then again well he's the
same
is it a round room lapsing you let it
bug ya waxing philosophical about robots
Tyrese Gibson Irene aren't you in this
where are you busy doing it fast and
furious 8 you couldn't stop by Michael
basic does have a more prominent role in
the Fast & Furious films when he does
any of these transformers so I
understand he's doing this hey I got a
maid there's a lack of slow-mo in this
trailer which I loved as I felt like
even though this trailer did the job of
badass and epic despite whatever
preconceived notions you might have I
still feel like they did a different
kind of trailer - as opposed to their
other trailers here's the thing like I I
also will save for this trailer I do
like some of the shots we saw because it
seems like they're at least framing this
in a more picturesque and perhaps a more
symmetrical or composed kind of way I
love a good jingle but you know like you
watch a Michael Bay movie most of the
time and it's like a music video and
like stuff's tilting and like every shot
it's so [ __ ] cool and you're like
this one seems like it's at least
visually trying to go along with its
this is big sci-fi yeah you know look
and that's cool to me
like the the look look hope good it's
what our great President Obama says
America subscribe to the real rejects
John is reason to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram as a social media manager
Facebook sites of the Blum house and the
real rejects I reject what you think of
the Transformers trailer put your
[ __ ] opinions down what the [ __ ]
Eric